welcome to the CEO playing em western
international master Emma Western got no
name there is there some m western like
Mike Weston I don't I don't know ok we
have a symmetrical english i play one of
the many lines that black has available
Bishop f5 intending 27 Bishop 83 and Joe
just generally developing aha
interesting
okay maybe I can skype a bit here at
least okay let's uh let's see is there
some some weird weird play with H form
probably not
my idea is to go to f5
hey might you might oops plate oops come
on play for default open up the center
nope he isn't
yeah the snow loops makes my maneuver
looker quite quite okay I think okay
night to defy FL he just attacks e7
hmm
well II six does not have six this is I
cannot play pawn to f6 looks plain ugly
like really ugly but it would support
age form
hmm
I somehow retract them attracted to this
age for move which looks completely
bonkers
come on let's let's let's try that just
just for fun and see what happens if you
place Bishop takes I play f6f 6i gyf
winning this bishop okay very quickly
played let's see the problem is if he
takes with the H porn yeah now i have
Bishop g4 this was my IDM to get this
Bishop to g4
yeah of course this whole configuration
is very problematic I cannot castle but
I still I still wanted to try yawa he
can he can just go Queen age six for
example egg nonsense Queen d2 I mean I
was thinking about Bishop h6 I am all
this was probably not a good idea the
problem it really is that TM that he has
90 of six all the time
and I wonder if I can actually play for
high queen sacrifice with Queenie 6 yeah
it's probably probably completely bong
completely completely insane but Knight
f6 is yeah well all this was was a load
of note of nonsense okay let's let's do
this Queen sec check okay the problem is
yeah probably this one the problem is if
five if I manage if he lets me play
Bishop b5 then this is all most
interesting okay he allows me to do that
I really would have played me five
opening up now I have some ideas rook
age 50 okay Jade and the position is
quite quite closed
yeah well maybe is cook enough to open
up on the queenside as possible
queen 85
it's probably the big problem if I go No
well now isn't this something g5
I don't know I feel like you're getting
something in this position I thought you
wouldn't he needs to play with Queen a
five at some point yeah this is
dangerous now all my pieces I in play
and I Bishop b5 everything sir working
nicely together yeah I can even take
here because of 92 at the end but I want
to don't want to exchange stuff
ideally I want to take with the bishop
and we treat it so that everything is in
play again yeah I don't think the Queen
sack was entirely correct but them with
Queen f2 yeah I can't i can draw now if
I want I don't want I don't want to draw
check
hard hard I only have 28 seconds and now
is playing for win check
yeah widest verse in this position he's
playing for the time
check
Knight f3
time warning
check
check
check
you
check
you had this with with enough time this
is a relatively easy win but with nine
seconds hmm check check
yeah why not coordinate easily with with
with five seconds even the firm this is
really a bit heartbreaking to lose it I
mean after the Queen sec and so on check
yeah come on it's it's a timeless any
way back what fits on time yeah when to
spend too much time and I didn't find a
complete win I mainly defended this
really terribly to be honest but giving
me everything but I don't really jack I
didn't really see a win I mean I saw
Bishop g3 here but i thought this this
what would hold I mean considering the
time check this kind of stuff leads to a
better end game for black because of the
the better minor pieces got everything
on on light squares but I thought I
needed more because of the time chatter
well this is just justice just a
playfulness banking on the time check
yeah and here I'm I can just meet I'm
such an idiot check and mate check
checkmate ah ah how much time i had 20
seconds on the clock yeah i mean this
move looked completely crochet to me but
I didn't really see why check even this
is go check check yeah i mean i don't
know it's not a matter of chess it's
just a matter of the time at this at
this at this spot i think what he what
he needed to do instead of after the
Queen sec he should play when doing here
he should this was ok but Queen f2 was
just just for what you can you need
Queen a five and counter play I think to
to defend our King f2 for example Luke
takes rook age one I mean this is this
is defendable easily for wide so well my
idea was giving up his seven was just it
was just was just just bad and after the
Kojak sec I should just lose but here it
gave it away and I didn't take it
alright thanks for watching